Globes host Ricky Gervais is going to
see a lot of tan faces when he takes the
stage Sunday on NBC for the fifth time I
did it the first time because it was a
big opportunity it was very flattering
then they invited me that I thought I
will do it again coz I think I can do a
better job so I haven't even seen the
Taurus who has after the second everyone
said I'd never be invited back have you
seen the tourists yet no there's a
fourth time relax I'm gonna try and be
nice but this is the last time there's a
limit there is a limit
Ricky revealed he's not getting drunken
improvising his jabs he actually spends
a lot of time writing those insults we
love and it's not to be taken seriously
because we're all gonna die soon
Ricky's jokes won't fall flat and
neither will demo at the official
champagne of the Golden Globes
there will be 750 bottles plus 1500
minis and 500 golden hour cocktails and
this year for the first time the globe's
are going vegan 120 cooks and 300
servers will plate some 10,000 meals
throughout the night
Leo was quick to praise the move to a
plant-based menu the main course will be
mushroom scallops their King oyster
mushrooms that are cut and cooked to
appear like scallops and thus are surely
won't skip any of the 1,200 dessert
plates and they can start on their diets
again on Monday here on the red carpet
we are bringing back our very own lucky
charm miss Sharon Osbourne will be back
to interview and gush over all the stars
she also doesn't mind putting them in
their place
no that's why we love her no fear and no
filter
[Music]